when you think of fighting games you
probably think of the iconic arcade
controller or fight stick for years the
greatest fighting game Masters cut their
teeth in arcades and at home with
joysticks and six button setups but for
more than a decade a challenger has
waited in the shadows it has widened its
influence drawn in new followers and
spread throughout the fighting game
Community the hitbox and a number of
other leverless controllers are rapidly
picking up steam and some of the best
players in the world are throwing away
their sticks and picking one up the
problem is that some people think that
using one is
well
cheating dude it's just science you can
push both buttons at the same time an
arcade stick cannot push left and right
at the same time just looking at it I'm
like I don't know how anyone can take a
look at that and say that it is not
cheating and the Evo 2022 Street Fighter
champion and many of his opponents used
a hitbox it's quickly become the hottest
Topic in the fighting game community so
today we are going to take a look at the
hitbox controversy
strap yourselves in
this one's gonna be a rough ride
[Applause]
before we get into the video I just want
to let you all know that we have merch
if you have yet to pick up a hoodie or
sweatshirt or t-shirt well I don't know
what you're waiting for you're
definitely not too busy touching grass
or anything anyway so if you didn't play
fighting games back in the day you might
be surprised to learn that prior to 2009
things weren't so hot but Street Fighter
4 changed all of that and led by the
legends of old a generation of new
players stepped forward to carry
fighting games into another decade while
many of those players used what was at
hand a controller or pad in many cases
some emulated the pros and bought or
built a fight stick more than anything
else fight sticks aimed to reproduce the
arcade experience but while newcomers
were buying into levered joysticks a new
controversial Challenger was waiting in
the wing in 2010 two brothers Sean and
Dustin Huffer decided that a fight stick
didn't have to have well a stick you
know what to call them because they're
not actually sticks they're just kind of
boxes so these are our boxes like uh we
made uh we're making different kinds
kind of messing around with different
schemes this one's uh this one's kind of
the standard one for Street Fighter or
basically uh the main difference is we
got arrow keys like if you're playing on
a keyboard for the for the directional
inputs the idea was simple what if you
could use the buttons from arcade sticks
to build a leverless controller pretty
much the only reason you'd want to do
this is because the travel time on a
joystick is a lot longer than the travel
time on like these sanwa buttons so
basically you can do you Dragon punch
your hadouken at light speed but even in
the comments of this video with less
than 30 000 views you can see the debate
start to Bubble Up will this thing even
be legal long term should we be
investing in something like this but the
orders started rolling in so the
brothers turned their garage into an ER
SATs assembly line and continued
producing them now some of you might be
thinking of course it's easier to press
four buttons than move a lever around
think about a stick's travel time you're
charging back it goes forward has to go
back
being able to hit both buttons at the
same time you are charging your next
Sonic Boom faster than the guy who's
using a stick and it's math it's not
opinion it's not oh this is harder to do
on hitbox this is easier to do this is
not opinion this is science like that's
been how FPS has worked on PC for a
pretty long time it's why you use was
controls and your keyboard doesn't have
a stick on it probably but even so if
those prototype hitbox controllers
appeared all the way back in 2010
why are we only hearing about them now
well you see in 2010 there were tons of
brand new fighting game players who
probably had the cash to buy a tried and
tested fight stick but probably weren't
in the know enough to Shell out for a
hitbox and while stick modding gained a
lot of popularity during this time it
wasn't like people were itching to yank
out their lever the discussion simmered
for a while and some pros did switch
but none made more waves than the Beast
himself Daigo
umehara
foreign
Daigo considered to be the greatest
Street Fighter player of all time
decided to switch to a leverless
controller and the debate fully entered
the mainstream fgc Consciousness it was
another tidal shift for fighting games
so I guess it's time to move away from
history and towards the exciting world
of
socd cleaning and now the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
where there's a big fancy acronym you
can be sure that I'm not far behind now
one of the biggest differences between
levered and leverless controllers is the
ability to input left and right or up
and down at the same time this is called
simultaneous opposing cardinal
directions or socd and it's at the core
of what has made the hitbox and other
leverless controllers so controversial
before hitboxes went mainstream games
often wouldn't know what to do with socd
inputs in Marvel 3 for example it
actually just sends both inputs to the
game so you could essentially Block in
both directions at once or just break
the game games just weren't designed to
deal with these conflicting inputs so
they had to be cleaned essentially
either the hardware the controller or
the software the game would have to
actually decide what to do with them to
break it down for you these are the
three most common ways to clean those
inputs there's neutral which doesn't
send either input until one of the
buttons is released last input priority
which sends whatever the last input was
or absolute priority which forces a
specific Direction when socd is inputted
for example up plus down always defaults
to up and that was the guy who actually
knows what he's talking about now
Diego's controller was controversial
partly because it used last input
priority or last win cleaning the
effects of this on Street Fighter 5's
guile were immediately obvious in a game
that literally counts every frame
um
foreign
Capcom came out and said that the use of
the controller gives the competition an
advantage that does not follow the
spirit of the Capcom Pro Tour before
they banned it now Daigo didn't get to
use his leverless controller at combo
breaker but he committed to continue to
practice both kinds of controllers since
it was allowed at subsequent tournaments
the debate never really died but this
event sparked a whole new round of
awareness and arguments slowly but
surely all kinds of leverless
controllers were explicitly made legal
at major tournaments then in August 2022
Daigo became an official brand
ambassador for hitbox
foreign
[Music]
now there will be people in the audience
who rightly reply that controllers can
also do this and yeah it's true if you
have a controller with both a d-pad and
a thumbstick you can actually send both
inputs at once but let's be real it's
not as if banning pads is a realistic
solution the fighting game Community is
so Niche and so small that alienating a
group of it is a really bad idea that
[__] is already on life control so you
are going to then take this small
community and remove a big part of it
one more thing the claims about reaction
times are actually pretty convincing
toquito one of the great legendary
Japanese Pros actually did a comparison
of both inputs
foreign
difference to an elite fighting game
player
is an eternity the hitbox represents an
advance in efficiency sure but sometimes
that efficiency can enable strategies
that weren't considered effective before
that doesn't mean that a hitbox is
better at everything there are some
inputs like 720s and half circles that
might actually be easier on stick and
that might actually be a bigger Factor
when determining whether hitbox will
remain competitive in the future if
you've ever played Street Fighter 2 you
probably realized that older games do
very little to help you input a special
move but modern fighting games are
designed to give the player a bit of
leeway in terms of input and a hitbox is
sometimes able to turn that leniency
into input shortcuts now if that
leniency were to change things might be
different because the input leniency in
this game is super free all you need is
a down a forward input a down and a
forward input
because she
is
foreign
squishy
um
still if this leniency does change it
will be a reversal of most recent Trends
in fighting games so from the standpoint
of pure Effectiveness it does seem as if
the hitbox is here to stay so where are
we now and what does the future hold for
the hitbox right now in 2022 Capcom
forces socd cleaning on conflicting Left
Right inputs and forces up or neutral on
conflicting up down inputs and if we had
to guess the former will probably become
the standard while the latter will
probably change everyone is living in a
post-hit box world right now and top
players are switching over a mess of the
top eight players for Street Fighter 5
at Evo 2022 five of them were using
leverless controllers including Daigo
umehara third place finisher gachikun
and the champion kawano and even if
sticks don't Disappear Completely this
could be the first time in fighting game
history that joysticks take a back seat
foreign
the question is whether hitbox should
take over the fgc because let me tell
you there are lots of people who don't
think it should for one allowing hitbox
could be the start of a technological
arms race imagine a world where everyone
is constantly adding new features to
their controllers it would be a
nightmare for players and toes if you're
gonna cheat and use a hitbox I would put
as many buttons as I want on it I would
put them exactly where I want them to be
and I would maximize on the cheatingness
so if there's any way for you to make it
so that both sides you know left and
right are active at the same time
whatever it is I recommend you ban those
rules as far as they'll go but don't
break them and to just say okay sure let
players do whatever they want and we'll
just make up the rules as we go feels a
lot like the let the athletes cheat all
they want as long as the playing field
Builders level argument it really is
similar to a corked bat a corked bat is
banned because it allows someone who is
an expert at hitting home runs to hit
them even further but it doesn't mean
that if you give rip a corked bat hey
hit a home run he's not going to be able
to do it you know it's not a miracle
worker but what it does do is it takes
someone who's an expert and elevates
them to a level that really the gamer is
just not designed that way now some of
the discussion often revolves around the
difficulty of adapting to actually using
the hitbox there's some [__] that's free
out of the gate but hitbox is not
intuitive forward diagonal down socd
because left and right they cancel each
other out
meaning you get down individually and
then I release in that same order so
[Music]
honestly top players will adapt winning
is literally their job plus while hitbox
may not seem intuitive if you're a
fighting game Die Hard who grew up with
a sanwa in your hands many new players
coming to fighting games have experience
with PC gaming so they've probably used
was controls so if it's not going to be
banned fighting game developers will
need to consider the existence of the
hitbox when designing future titles if
they break the games in hitbox to me I'm
thinking forward developers need to
consider hitbox in the future with their
input uh reading systems and with their
with their design philosophy and their
balancing but like we said earlier it's
not all bad news for sticks there are
plenty of attempts out there to give
joystick wielding Boomers a Competitive
Edge against the hitbox legion but I'm
gonna be honest with you all right now
hitboxes are taking over that's not
necessarily a bad thing but it is the
truth in a world with nothing but lever
joysticks and controllers it might be
fair to say that the hitbox is cheating
but that World Is Gone partly because
developers failed to act until they were
forced and
maybe people are holding on to fight
sticks out of sentimentality either way
it's up to developers to ensure that
hitbox users don't get any unfair
advantages they need to make clear
concise rulings about socd mandate and
enforce what they want on the software
side and be actively involved with what
can and cannot be used to play their
games and for retro games which won't
have software side cleaning we need to
figure out how exactly to approach
hitbox as a community maybe that means
fight sticks will slowly disappear or be
relegated to museums or maybe it means
that they'll get some extra help but
what it almost certainly means is that
like it or not hitboxes
are here to stay
so this is Colton's section or mine it's
Gotta Be Colton's yay okay okay perfect
I think this is a rare case I think what
happens I think Josh wrote the section
because it's so [__] turbo version
that oh my gosh only Josh would know
this Daigo didn't get to use his
leverless controller at combo breaker
but he can I have a combo breaker went
full Midwest there